so um outside of
religion what else are your deal
breakers like so you have to have the
same religion as a girl
more times than not
abraham abrahamic faith okay but more
more times like i will probably lean
towards uh christian and you're his
friend so does he does he only date does
he only date the christian girls i don't
know what he dates i just met trav i'm
glad i'm fortunate to meet this oh you
just met him i thought you guys knew
each other
i noticed in august he's a great guy
stand-up guy
mind me i can't speak on him but me
personally
my deal breakers
will be people
that really don't have no driving
motivation like i said i was raised by a
single mother so i get out the mud
so i don't want anybody that's lazy i
want no one that doesn't have no
ambition like i don't care
where you are in your life at this stage
when you're speaking when you're when
we're speaking
you have to tell like if we're talking
you say what do you want to do in the
future
you have to tell me oh my plans to do
this and that are you have an idea if
you're just sitting around okay so what
else what else what
else what else yeah
looks
like
it's the rem
pretty attractive people in my life we
are high attract people that i won't
talk to but hey i'm all about
connections we are heterosexual men who
are attracted to creatures
would you guys date a girl that's
overweight
no i have a six-pack
jesus christ god
i want somebody that has a quote-unquote
active lifestyle
and
i probably attract people in that
section so
no dis but i don't think overweight
people single mom
single mom better response a better
response
hey
a better response would have been
that's just not my preference
it's not about practice because hey
i have a personal training certificate
i'll put her to work
i'm getting twisted
tonight
i'm sorry i have to recuperate because
you did you date a girl as a kid though
yeah this means honestly
my my oldest brother my oldest brother
he is dating a woman well it's her
fiance now they could get married
in uh july mm-hmm and
when i came to london for the first time
i came back to london for the first time
he was dating a lady and she had a child
already but the way they had the
relationship
her child and then my my brother it was
just so like seamless and you felt like
it's just as natural having a child
doesn't really affect me in general like
if i really love you i love your child
at the same time yes so that's not
really a deal breaker in my opinion
if you have someone that's toxic in a
relationship then it might be a factor
where it goes let's say your your ex
partner with them you don't have a good
relationship with it
it might be a little techie it might be
it might ruin our hinder things
especially
you having a child in general mm-hmm
doesn't really affect how i feel about
you and if i
if i love you and i feel like i can take
you seriously then obviously i'll be in
the workforce i would
i love kids i just
i think
like you so you don't rate it no i mean
look at i love i really do like i love
kids like i get really excited when i
see babies because they're like all
chubby and stuff you know
but um i don't know i just feel like
there's something special about like
having your first child like with
somebody that's someone that already
yeah yeah like together and i just don't
like it's like a bond you're supposed to
have with like one person i think but
you don't think
you can love their you can know you
don't think you can love their child and
then have your own child with them
i think i think i absolutely could but i
would just rather not like i would just
rather date someone without kids
earlier
did you not say you could have multiple
soul partners or did i make that i was
soul ties so yeah oh
i don't believe in soul mates i think we
choose who we date
and i think you're who you date and
attract is based on your choices like if
i gained 100 pounds i think my partner
would be very different
all right so
so if you if you dated somebody and you
thought you loved them and then had a
child
would there would that then eliminate
you from
dating anyone else because
you've got a special tie with that
person
if i wait i had the kid
yes you had the child well i think if i
had a kid that would eliminate like a
lot of guys probably wouldn't want to
date me because i had the kid
but there's still guys that will date
yeah they would women who have children
there's good guys out there
no i know but i don't think it makes
someone a bad guy because they don't
want to date someone with kids
oh that's what he said that's what he's
just don't look good
those
no i think
what would you say
those words didn't come from oh okay
okay okay are archer thinks different
all right so even though we do agree on
certain things or some things this is uh
this is the uh it's the actual youtube
thing the admin oh wait the bot is
getting on to you because you keep on
sniffing
well the reason why i keep on sniffing
is because i have a condition called
adam noise hey who's lemonade that's my
moderator yeah that's the moderator
sorry